a death 14 years ago in a Las Vegas
motel is back in the spotlight after it
was recently featured on the Netflix
show on South Mysteries so now the
dog reopened and she sat down with eight
news now investigator Vanessa Murphy to
explain why she believes there was Foul
Play
this is a new season new shooting James
barrier also known as Buffalo Jim was a
character
wrestling promoter auto shop owner but
to Jennifer barrier I want to know what
happened to my father he was dead I have
been on a quest for truth and Justice
since day one
14 years ago Buffalo Jim's body was
found in a Las Vegas motel room his
death was ruled accidental due to a drug
overdose but Jennifer believes he was
murdered I personally think that my
father was poisoned he said they might
try to get him attorney Gus flanges says
he also believes Foul Play was involved
everything in this stinks
and they deserve justice flank has sent
this
letter to the attorney general and the
Clark County district attorney
requesting an investigation and
highlighting what he believes are
numerous inconsistencies in the case
he points to a feud between buffalo Jim
and the former owner of a strip club he
says Buffalo Jim had been working as an
informant the club owner spent time in
prison and Jennifer says he was released
just days before her dad's death while
police documents point to a cocaine
overdose flanges says he also had GHB
also known as liquid ecstasy in his
system yet that was not investigated
and the last person believed to have
been with Buffalo Jim a woman named Lisa
flanges says her story to police changed
and at one point she said it appeared
Buffalo Jim was having a seizure despite
being a so-called friend she left him
there the eight news now investigators
tracked her down by phone she said no
comment and hung up and if it turns out
that's what happened he just overdosed
accidentally that's something that would
need to be confirmed one way or the
other I will tell you right now if they
do a really deep dive that's not going
to be the case with women arrier says
her father had been receiving
threatening letters he was warned a
woman would lower him and she believes
he wouldn't have been using drugs there
might be some Skeptics
if he had been using cocaine and
partying and doing more than you believe
someone could say is he really going to
tell his teenage daughter is what what
he was doing right that's a valid
question
um I did ask the detective working on
the case to please get a hair sample
because that would show if he was a
long-term drug user but she claims that
never happened who should be held
accountable I feel that Metro needs to
take a closer look at what happened the
Clark County district attorney tells me
it's not up to his office to open an
investigation but if Metro Police
reopened the case his office will review
it it appears that won't happen though
Metro says the case is closed and the
investigation had concluded James
barrier's death was not a homicide
Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now
and our investigators also reached out
to the Attorney General's office a
spokesman confirms the letter was
received and the office has no further
comment